I am [INAUDIBLE] Khan, and I'm
doing a Ph.D. At MIT Sloan.
Prior to starting the Ph.D.,
I worked as a policy advisor
with the Dutch
government and Bangladesh
between 2013 and '15.
During the course of my
work, I interacted with many
stakeholders working on
occupational safety and health
issues at the workplace
and workers' rights,
particularly in the
Bangladeshi textile sector.
Amongst the stakeholders,
was Miss Nazma Akter
a prominent member of the
Bangladesh labor movement.
In a sector that is
largely dominated by men,
she stands out as the country's
most respected and influential
female labor leader.
She began her working life
at the tender age of 11,
in a small garment
factory in Dhaka.
As she grew older, she
started to speak out
against the injustices
at the workplace.
For this, she often
faced brutality
from thugs hired by the factory
managers, and even the police.
She eventually
left the workforce,
and went on to starting
the AWAJ Foundation
with some other coworkers.
AWAJ Foundation
is an organization
which fights for workers'
rights and helps settle
worker disputes in factories.
The organization has
been active in mediating
numerous activities on
wages, overtime, holidays,
and maternity
leave in factories.
Despite the hardships of
working in the garment sector,
Miss Akbar is not against
garment factories,
which she believes empower
women by giving them
greater choice and opportunity.
However, she is
resolutely against
exploitative and dangerous
working practices,
and strives to ensure that
women get treated fairly.
I had the opportunity
to speak with her,
in Bangladesh in January 2016
on a number of current issues
facing the Bangladesh
labor movement.
As a worker in
Bangladesh, Ms. Akter
is vocal on the subject of the
exploitation of cheap labor
by the first oil companies.
And eloquently puts
forth the conflict
between the vested
interests groups
and Bangladeshi workers
in the factories.
Thank you to MIT to
give me the opportunity.
As you know, the most of
the production country
where producing the garments
is the buyers an international
and fresh and original.
They're coming to me
because of the cheap labor.
Especially the Bangladesh is
the cheapest all over the world.
So that means that globally,
people are addressing us.
[INAUDIBLE] and pull and pull.
So, if you're addressing
this kind of world,
there is no human interaction,
there is no worker [INAUDIBLE],
there is not decent
working conditions.
This is the global
problem who is created
by the global people and
global business community
and the legislation.
So that need to be addressed.
How people have to get the
decent working condition.
A decent working condition.
Living condition.
Because that is very
needed to for us.
And in many cases the
Bangladeshi and other branches,
the business people are so
powerful in the parliament,
in the government.
Also, they're highly educated.
That is the problem with this.
The politics is always
favored for the big business.
Secularism and globalization
is a big, bad impact
for the general people and
for the working people.
So how we have to
get the equal rights.
And we have to be thinking
about the respect and dignity.
Not only the profit and profile.
Because capitalism
has only two results.
One is profit.
Another is the control.
So they have both,
and we are hungry.
So we need to stop the hunger.
And we need to be decent.
And ensure the nutrition.
She goes on to elaborate on
the specific challenges she
faced in her work, and the kind
of disputes she has observed.
As you know, the workers
has main fundamental right
to collective bargaining
that negotiation
and the union right.
Which is very challenges
and difficult for us,
because when the workers
are organize the union,
most of the case there
are finding that union
busting from the men is meant.
As is the local politician,
and local people.
And their fear, they're
given threat, they're beaten,
they're given the different
types of pressure, and abuse.
And they file a false case.
And this is very
difficult to organize.
And as activist, and leader, we
are also facing problem also.
With as many cases as I told
before, [INAUDIBLE] powerful,
and they also the
only ones that's
involved in the
parliament and the power.
So that kind of
difficulty we are facing.
In many cases,
they're so difficult,
and challenges many
workers are the facing.
They are also--
[INAUDIBLE] one or
two countries safe
again, because it's very
threatened what they're like.
So, these are the challenges
we need to ensure.
And corruption is it
one of the big problems,
and government is not serious
about the workers issues,
than the business profit.
So we want to build
a relationship
and worker-management
dialogue in same platform.
It will be helpful for
the productivity, as well
as the workers' happiness.
So if that begin, the
sustainable development
comes after.
We built one part,
only the manufacturer
are taking their own
decision, their won things.
It will not work, because
the manufacturer always
want [INAUDIBLE].
Maximum things, like when we are
asking for the workers benefit.
That is honest minimal things.
So how we have to
get the maximum.
And how we to get that.
[INAUDIBLE]
The Rana Plaza incident,
where over 1,100 workers
died when their
factory collapsed,
resulted in many initiatives--
both within
Bangladesh, and abroad.
And money poured in
from many sectors.
When I asked her what she
thought of those initiatives,
she was skeptical.
She also had high
expectations from the meeting
of the sustainability compact
held in Bangladesh in 2016.
The compact was an agreement
signed between the governments
of Bangladesh, the
EU, and the US,
following the Rana
Plaza collapse,
in an effort to improve
working conditions
in the textile sector.
After Rana Plaza collapse,
lots of initiating
taken by Bangladesh,
and all the world.
It is so many meeting,
so many seminars,
so many things agreeing, and so
many funded and support we got.
But the real things, and
real effort was not done.
Many cases, we found many
days is not that much.
So our request, the money should
be utilized the right person,
workers as the industry.
But in many cases,
it's not working.
In many cases, found
is like an eyewash
or trying to be
useful in this use.
As you know, the third
Compact Sustainability meeting
will be held on 28th of
January, Dhaka, Bangladesh.
We are expecting-- to
the Compact meeting--
the Bangladesh
government, and you'll
get an American delegate.
Already you know the
sustainable development goals.
There are 17 goals.
The goal number 8
is a decent one.
So we wanted the decent
ones-- addressing
and how to implement.
And we want to be living with--
we want freedom of association
and fundamental rights.
And we want better
workers-management relations.
And people are very poor--
want a better living condition,
as in these safety issues.
When I asked her
about how to improve
worker-employer relations,
she had important insights
about how to build relationships
that benefit both parties.
If we really want a functional
workers-management relation,
that is--
that part, we need to
educate all of them.
And also we need to create a
workers-management relation
culture, because that
is the big problem.
And management needs
to be positive thinking
and positive way to
accept the issues.
Because always they are
thinking we are invested--
we are not listening to anyone.
The workers have
to be listening.
So that type of culture
and motivation--
also need, as the global
suppliers and the buyer
have also responsibility to
ensure these kind of things.
But in many cases we
found they are absent.
So everybody needs to
be working together.
As the workers representative,
we need a constructive union.
And also management
has to be constructive,
as does the buyer.
So-- and government should
be supporting all of them.
I think this way
we can overcome.
If there was one party to
initiate it, it will not work.
She ends with a strong
message to the new generation
in the West--
the current and future
consumers of textiles,
who will play an important
role in determining the future
of global supply patterns.
As you know, most of the goods
are produced by the young boys
and girls.
And that is the important
issue, because they
don't get proper education
and proper food and nutrition.
That is why they need
to be voluntarily
early retirements because
of the malnutrition
and high production pressure.
My request to all
the young consumers
who will be the next
generation leaders
of taking that responsibility--
you have to respect your
young friends and colleagues
who are working
in Bangladesh, how
to ensure their [INAUDIBLE]
end of their life,
and workplace safety
and other issues.
Because the young
generation can take
all that initiating, because
you are the consumer.
And you are the right people.
So please try to be ensured
and while carefully to safe
working conditions and
decent living conditions.